Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's February 28, 2023.
It's ActInf lab GuestStream number 37.1.
And we're here with Baba Brinkman.
This should be a great discussion and
emergence.
Baba, thank you so much for joining.
Let's just jump right into it.
What brings you to this day?
How and who are you?
Baba: Thanks, Daniel, so much for having
me here.
It's a real honor to join you and to dip
into this community, which I've been
aware of for a while, and like to try to
follow the work as much as I can.
But I'm not a scientist myself.
I'm a rapper.
I have been exploring academic topics in
hip hop for quite a while.
I did my master's thesis on Chaucer's
Canterbury tales.
I was a Renaissance and medieval scholar
and I rewrote the Canterbury Tales into
rap.
And I used to tour around the UK rapping
my Wife of Bath's Tale and Miller's Tale
renditions, which was a lot of fun.
And then at one point, it was around 2007
or 2008, an evolutionary biologist, a
geneticist, saw my Canterbury Tales show,
and he reached out to me and said, I love
what you're doing for medieval
literature, popularizing it with rap, but
there's other topics that need rap
popularization.
I think his exact words were, would you
be willing to do for Darwin what you did
for Chaucer?
And this was in the run up to the Darwin
bicentennial in 2009.
It was the 200th anniversary of the birth
of Charles Darwin, also the 150th
anniversary of the publication of The
Origin of Species.
I was, of course, a big fan of Darwin and
of evolutionary theory, but not very
expert.
So I said to this scientist, yes, I'll
write some raps about evolution, but I
could use some guidance.
He sent me a whole bunch of suggested
reading sources, books, peer reviewed
papers, everything.
So I took a sort of six month deep dive
on the state of evolutionary theory,
absorbed a whole bunch of books, and
wrote these rhymes.
But his criteria was, your performances
will be at academic seminars with experts
in Darwinian evolution across all kinds
of social domains and psychology and
everything.
So you need to make sure you represent
the theory accurately, which means you
have to run your lyrics by me so I can
check them for scientific veracity, which
I thought was a fair criteria for that
kind of context.
So I sent him my lyrics.
He gave me some revision suggestions.
And then when I was set to perform the
premiere of my Darwin show on Darwin Day,
February 12, 2009, the scientist, his
name is Mark Palin.
He was a bacterial geneticist.
He had this great intro, typical British
tongue in cheek style.
He was like, I have fact checked the
lyrics, and you're about to witness the
first rap show in history
that's peer reviewed.
I was like, Peer reviewed rap?
That's a great idea.
Totally marks coinage.
But then right away, the wheels started
spinning like what other topics could you
apply the peer reviewed rap lens to?
So I did my Evolution rap show for
several years.
It was called the Rap Guide to
Evolution.
It played off Broadway, won an award at
the Edinburgh Fringe Festival, and then
other scientists started tugging me on
the sleeve like, oh, the Darwin wraps are
cool, but could you do wilderness
conservation and threatened species
ecology?
Could you do climate change?
Could you do neuroscience?
And various great collaborations came
from that.
So we now have a whole series of rap
albums, rap guides to various topics.
And my encounter with the active
inference community and research base was
when I was working on one called The Rap
Guide to Consciousness.
And Professor Anil Seth is one of the, I
think, main proponents and contributors
to the Bayesian brain active inference
research paradigm today.
And he was one of the main science
advisors on the project.
So he was giving me Bayesian stuff to
read,
including Andy Clark's
What's Next?
Highly technical review of all the
literature which I slogged my way through
as a nonexpert and ended up working
Bayesian ideas quite in a detailed way
into the Rap Guide to Consciousness
show.
And what really resonated for me,
honestly, I had never really paid
attention to Bayes’ Theorem or Bayesian
reasoning at all, but it took me a while
to get my head around it.
But then I was like, okay, this is
actually just a great paraphrase of the
scientific method.
And I was already a massive proponent of
the scientific method, and I was geeking
out on the degree to which the brain may
be a Bayesian engine at the microscopic
level, producing a rational inquiry
process that replicates the exact same
Bayesian algorithm at the level of
interactions with society.
So I did one song in the show called Good
Bayesian:
Baba rapping: “Let me show
you how to be a good Bayesian and change
your predictions after taking
information.
And if you're thinking I’ll be less than
amazing, let's adjust those
expectations!”
Baba: And I was right away thinking
about, like, how is a rap performance
itself an instantiation of a Bayesian
algorithm with the audience's
expectations being revised in real time
based on the rapper's performance and the
rappers expectations when creating the
script of the performance about what
reaction they'll get from the audience,
which is a prior belief about the
effectiveness of the performance.
But when it's only a script, you don't
actually know what's going to work.
And then you do the performance, you see
what gets the reaction, you revise your
priors and you also revise your script.
And that was a concept that I had already
been rapping about in my Evolution show.
I have a show whole song, and that called
performance feedback revision, which
instantiates the kind of evolutionary
natural selection algorithm.
But at the level of creative writing and
performance, you write the script, you do
the show, you see how people react, you
go back, change the script and that's
kind of like the genome being revised
under phenotypic variants and how they
end up surviving or not surviving,
reproducing and not reproducing.
I just started out wrapping and trying to
master the craft and each scientific
topic I get into I start going, oh, this
actually helps me understand what's going
on in rap much better.
And especially, actually one of the
examples I play with in the show, which
is a lot of fun, is like call and
response expectations of the audience.
Like a perfect kind of demonstration of a
Bayesian moment when you go double take,
look twice, calculate the odds, roll the
and when I do that the whole crowd would
be like dice.
But the expectation of what the rhyme
couplet is going to be is a game rappers
play all the time, like finish the bar,
right?
And that is entirely around a setup of an
expectation and the fulfillment of it,
but then sometimes you can play with it
and be like yo perceptual basics.
Baba rapping: As morpheus.
Baba: We live in the and I usually get
the crowd being like, matrix back at me,
but then other times I'd make it more
difficult.
Like, yo, perceptual basics, lady bugs
like to eat.
And then maybe one person out of 100
would be like, Aphids.
And I'd be like, yeah, that was a person
that had the correct scientific Bayesian
priors to conclude my matrix basics
aphids rhyme pattern.
But usually only a few get it.
And then everyone else is like, there's
the nerd over there or whatever.
So it's become like actually informed my
creative process in terms of how I try to
set up and violate expectations in real
time psychologically with an audience
when I'm performing.
And I will be honest that my close
reading of the research was several years
ago at this point the Rap Guide to
Consciousness came out in 2017.
18 I was performing it off Broadway, 19 I
was touring it around theaters in the UK
and still performing it off Broadway and
then 20, of course, all performances
ceased altogether and I had to think
about what rappers do in pandemics when
they can't get on stages and see crowds.
So yeah, we can talk during this
interview about my new project, which is
a custom wrap agency.
You can see me wrapping it right here.
Event wrap, which could be fun to talk
about in terms of the event inference,
elements of active inference and Bayesian
analysis.
Could be, I think, some of the aspects of
what attract me to events, what attracted
me to events during the Pandemics, and
still does, as a sort of catalyst for
good art and for rap, might have to do
with active inference, expectations and
experiences.
But I don't know this literature very
closely at this point.
So yeah, that basically brings us up to
the present.
Hopefully that was a good summary.
Daniel: Amazing, just great to connect
and to be able to share this moment with
someone who's seen it from all sides in
front of the stage, on stage, behind
stage, inside the mind.
Real, recognize, real.
So there's a lot out there.
And just like as if we were.
Baba: Talking about a paper, real,
recognize, real.
Namaste.
Daniel: If we were talking about a paper,
we would read between the lines and
reference out.
And similarly, there's so much that can
be referenced out and people can listen
to the original creations and see what
that primary text looks like.
And the fact that it's an orally
performed text for much of human
development in history was are real.
So whether something is written is
increasingly fluid these days with speech
to text and text to speech.
So there's going to be so many great
avenues.
Let's just start with event based
cognitivist.
So what is an event from the cognitive
perspective?
Baba: I was trying to find that
definition with Google about 20 minutes
ago, so I didn't sound like an idiot in
this podcast.
So I think it's a perceptual construct,
right?
It is the perception of an entity that
there is some kind of instantiation of
action that is circumscribed in time,
that has a beginning and an end.
And if it's not perceived as having a
beginning and an end by some cognitive
entity, historically organisms, but in
the future also probably AIS, then it's
not treated as an event, which means an
event could be a thousand years or 5
seconds or whatever.
It's actually interesting how the kind of
the scientific definition of it in active
inference research really is like a
narrative definition in a way, right?
It's a story.
Something you can tell a story about,
something you can construct a story
around is an event.
Is that pretty close to how scientists
think about it?
Daniel: Yeah, I mean, already so much
there.
You're right.
It does not have to be tied to a given
amount of clock time, which we might call
chronology harkening back to chronos,
that sort of decimal point time.
But action takes place in the
understanding of the actor or the
observer in this timescale of action or
kairos.
And that timescale of action may be
narrative, and that is what you invoke
with the beginning, middle and end,
rising and falling cultural patterns.
That's not necessarily happening on the
clock.
Just because you can run a stopwatch
while somebody's reciting Canterbury
Tales doesn't mean that it'd be twice as
exciting if they spoke twice as fast, or
that you could map in some linear way
what was happening on the watch face to
what's happening in the mind of audience
who have different familiarity with the
material.
Baba: Or a historical study context as
well.
It just made me think of like, if I do a
ten minute long wrap of The Wife of
Bath's Tale, then that's an event.
I performed the Wife of Bath’s Tale.
There was an audience that witnessed it.
You could circumscribe it that way.
But you could do a scientific study on
what occurred during that event.
Right?
But you could also choose to study the
event of humanity's retelling of the
story of the Wife of Bath's Tale, which
is a story that takes place in King
Arthur's Court.
So now we know where the mythology has to
have started, which is around, you know
(forgive me, Medievalists!), but let's
say like four or 500 AD.
And then whenever the historical King
Arthur's court existed, and then there
was an oral mythology that adhered to
that over the course of a period of time
as people told folk tales about it.
And then in the year 1400, Geoffrey
Chaucer (well, I think he perished in
1400, so he was born in the 1330s)…
But he writes the Wife of Bath’s Tale at
some point as a written representation of
the oral narrative.
And then that vellum manuscript is passed
down into college reading lists and I
read it in 1998 and write a Rap version
of it.
So any study of humanity's engagement
with the story of the Wife of Bath Tail
has to really start in the year 400 and
end the last time I wrapped my Rap
version of the Wife of Bathtail at the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival, which was a
couple of years ago.
And no event that accounts for the
phenomenon of the telling of that story
can leave any of those instantiations
out.
Right.
Daniel: Awesome.
It's like the earlier events are our
prior or our generative process, which is
our niche, that events happen in our
generative model.
Our cognitive model exists within the
niche, the generative process.
And those prior events quite literally
are our priors.
And there's no last chapter because the
observations keep rolling in.
And whether the observation is exactly as
expected, whether that performance of
that symphony is exactly as expected,
whether that performance of the hamburger
or of the portrait, even if it's exactly
as expected, it still is a new
observation.
And then what is as expected?
Well, that's in the encultured cognitive
mind, and that is this sometimes implicit
reference point that novelty is
contrasted against, like, well, I knew I
was going to get a Rap summary, but I
didn't know it'd be that funny, or I
didn't know I was going to get a Rap
summary.
These are like different levels and types
of novelty about the story of a moment.
Baba: Or look at how he changed the story
from the archival version because there's
definitely a completely different
experience of people that are intimately
familiar with Chaucer's version and ones
who are hearing the story for the first
time and encountering each of the
characters.
This is the kind of expectation of how
accurately will the story be recounted in
this new version.
Also, let me just expand on something
that you said.
You said there's no last prior because
there's constant reinstantiations and
updating.
Right.
But there is a last plot prior from the
perspective of a temporary analysis of an
event.
You can set a sort of artificial
beginning and end for the purpose of
doing an analysis, and that's, I guess,
where you're able to apply mathematics to
it, but you always have to keep in mind
that it's a chosen beginning and endpoint
within a larger unfolding.
Daniel: Yeah.
And that's very resonance with my
experience as a researcher, which is
like, there is a final data point in any
time series at some point, the fMRI
machine or the ant foraging watching
machine, you just turn it off for the
day.
So there is empirically something that's
very addressable.
But in the general case, it's not the
case that a time series algorithm says
what the last observation is.
And we might even say that that's a
deflationary perspective on history,
because rather than debating whether
somebody has released the definitive
American novel or the last word on this
symphony, it's like, well, the last note
of their symphony was non
controversially, the last note of their
symphony.
But the question about the discourse and
the community, of course, there's no last
word in this open ended space, and art is
always like surfing on that open space.
Baba: One of the things I remember from
my comparative literature courses is this
idea of the anxiety of influence and how
poets have their I think it's maybe
Harold Bloom that wrote that, but poets
have a sense of needing to create
something new.
I think this general applies to art.
All artists, right?
Theater rappers.
This is like imagination conjures.
But of course, great art is produced on
the shoulders of a lot of influence in
the past.
And one of the measures in an English
literature course of whether a poem rises
to the level of worthiness to be studied
at university is the degree of impact it
had afterwards.
And that can sometimes be measured by how
many imitators it generated.
So one thing I always find fascinating is
you read 14th century literature and
Chaucer stands out as the main poet,
right?
You barely read any 15th century
literature in an English lit course, or
at least when I was in school in the 90s,
that was the case.
I've just gone all blurry heaven.
I want to see what's going on with my
camera here.
There we go.
Refocused.
The camera has its own priors.
So Chaucer shut down English literature
for, like, 100 years, and when I was in
an English survey course, I'm like, Why
do we read Chaucer in the 14th century?
And the next poet we read is the 16th
century.
What happened to the 15th century?
And my professors were like, well, every
poet that wrote poetry in the 15th
century was seen as so much of a Chaucer
knockoff and derivative because his style
was so influential that none of them rise
to the level of having contributed
anything distinctive until over 100 years
later.
I was like, wow, that is impact, right?
That is like as much impact as you.
But ironically, it's like negative
impact.
Like the most significant poem shuts
everybody up because they don't dare to
do anything except for imitated in a
totally derivative way.
But creating something new out of it,
that's what creates the most fecundity in
art, right?
Like, you create something.
And a lot of her people were like, oh, I
love this.
I'm going to take it and adapt it and run
with it.
That's one of the things I love about hip
hop, is it's so much about sampling and
flipping and remixing, and it's not
afraid of any other genre because its
attitude is you can take any genre and
make it better by adding beats and
rhymes.
But really effective art shuts it down.
I think Andrew Marvell was also known as
the last carpet diem poem writer because
he wrote such a perfect carpet diem poem,
Gather Ye Rosebuds while You May, that no
one really bothered with that genre
anymore because nobody could do as well
as Andrew Marvell.
And he wrote the last great garden poem
as well, english garden poem.
And it's like, how do you measure your
success as an artist?
By the degree to which you've created
something that's so intimidating for
everybody else that they don't even
bother with the genre anymore.
And now you're measuring your success by
the deletion of genres from the cultural
milieu, which creates space for other
people to invent more genres.
But this is an interesting way to measure
success.
Daniel: Wow.
I'm going to pick up on that pattern and
bring it into attention.
And the Bayesian perspective on
attention, which is sometimes equated
with precision.
So if we're paying a lot of attention to
a sensory input, a lot of attention, high
precision, we're really putting a lot of
credence in that information.
It's overriding our priors a lot.
We're updating our beliefs to basically
be what we're paying attention to.
And then the other case would be we're
not paying attention.
We have low precision or high
uncertainty, and we're not updating our
beliefs at all.
That's what we basically conversationally
mean when we say we're not paying
attention to that.
Like, I couldn't tell you what it was.
It didn't leave an impact.
And when you were talking about this
cultural evolutionary process, I thought
about cultures paying attention to genres
and works, because if there was one work
that was the object of attention, it
would be in the spotlight.
But attention is like a spotlight, and if
it's a laser on one thing, it's not on
everything else.
And if there's no work that's rising to
attention, then there's this
proliferation of hypotheses cultural
endeavors, but no one of them will
necessarily be shared.
And so art that resonates with
communities and with your friends.
It's like in this gray zone where it has
to have enough attention on it so that
there can be a culture of hip hop or the
Grateful Dean or whatever it may be, but
not one that is so attended to that it
gets burnt by the laser.
Baba: Yeah, it's like if everyone's only
paying attention to one thing then that's
actually very stifling for cultural
flourishing because you don't get all the
variants, you get these totally dominant
moments.
You can see that at the macro level in
history but it also just happens on
social media all the time too.
Right?
Everybody's talking about one thing and
then it's like what if that thing is not
interesting to you?
Or what is the upshot of that.
Daniel: Dominance of attention in active
inference?
We sometimes talk about regimes of
attention and there have been some great
recent papers on cultural regimes of
attention and that kind of takes that
basal Bayesian idea of attention as
precision to stimuli and it puts it into
the dynamical space where the regime of
attention might be like the sequence of
eye circades across a page.
So that is a complex pattern with
attention moving and we could just call
that broadly like a regime of attention
or attention and action.
And in some sense that's what culture is
or can be described as.
Baba: Is regime just a kind of summary of
where you happen to look or is the intent
that it's like there is some kind of
intentional control of attention that is
inherent to the work that's being
attended to.
Like you can expect people to look others
in the eyes when you're seeing a video or
a photo.
And the regime is that there must be some
implied, maybe an inbuilt psychology of
things that we tend to find more
fascinating.
Is that what's implied by it a.
Daniel: Lot there the word regime does
have a slight connotation of something
that's imposed whereas it is in the
neutral sense describing merely the
dynamics and then what those shared
regimes of attention might be like.
We're going to approach each other this
way, making this kind of eye contact and
make these kinds of gestures.
That's how we're going to be reducing our
uncertainty about who we are and what
this event is.
And without those shiboliths secret words
and implicit or explicit processes and
rituals, it's hard to lock on culturally
and there's so many ways to go from
there.
Baba: But I'll leave it yeah, whenever I
see chibolas and norms being acted out.
Obviously there are scientific studies
that are trying to unpack this as well.
But my favorite thing to speculate about
is to what degree is this culturally
constructed in an open ended way and to
what degree is the cultural aspects of it
relying on an underlying cognitivist
psychology that is inherited from
evolution?
Like for instance, if you're having a
conversation with somebody one on one and
you never look them in the eyes, that's
inherently suspicious, right?
Like, what's wrong with this person?
They won't look me in the eyes.
Are they lying to me?
Do they have something to hide that
response that you get emotionally and in
terms of somebody's disposition towards
you, I would find that very unlikely to
be 100% culturally constructed.
Could you imagine a society that was
egalitarian where they never looked each
other in the eyes?
I can imagine societies where aristocrats
prohibit people below them in the
hierarchy from looking in the eyes
because it's seen as a sign of
disrespect, which of course, is entirely
based on primate behavior.
When you're, like, challenging an alpha,
if you look at them for too long, then
they'll bite you and you got to cast your
eyes down to demonstrate your
submissiveness or whatever.
Humans have replicated some of these very
deep mammalian instincts that we have,
right?
But are we malleable enough that a
society could ever evolve with the norm
of nobody ever looks the other person in
the eyes?
Or would that swim upstream so strongly
against our instinctive ways of measuring
our degrees of trust and affinity towards
each other that that culture would just
inherently fail and not manage to be
represented in the panoply of cultures
going forward?
Daniel: I'll try to give a thought on
that.
Falling back to this attention
discussion.
So the movement of the eyes does provide
information.
Whether it's deceptive or not.
It is an outlet of information from the
person who you could be looking.
Baba: At putting attention itself right
where you look to find out if someone's
paying attention.
Daniel: The eyes are the window to the
soul.
Maybe that wasn't just about the cornea
attention as the window to the soul.
Baba: It was about game theory.
Daniel: And so to neglect this fountain
of information, you have to have a
cultural clamp on it, like a secondary
reason to not look, because it is
providing so much info on a millisecond
by millisecond level in ways that aren't
always even expressible.
Like pupil diameter has a lot to do with
arousal.
And psychologically, people may or may
not know about that empirically, and I
doubt it was shown empirically until we
had cameras and measuring devices and
millimeters and all of that.
But it can still play a role implicitly
in behaviors and heuristics and
strategies.
And so it's like if we're paying
attention to our embodiment, certain
things will arise.
And in situations where the inherited
prior has to overrule or reinterpret
those first principles takes those are
like scenarios with an attention to the
past, for better and worse.
That is shading our experience
interpretation versus the prima fascia
situational awareness that convergently
evolves to a few attractors like looking
at informative sources of information.
Baba: Yeah.
And just because there's a lot of
swimming upstream of sort of instinctive
cognition necessary for cultural norms to
play out, doesn't necessarily mean that
they're doomed to fail or a waste of time
or whatever you could almost say, like
the whole scientific enterprise, complex
mathematics, even reading, none of these
things are instinctively evolved.
They're all very recent, and we're like
building them on top of our older
cognition and architecture and
instincts.
But they're gloriously culturally
constructed and I would say worthy of the
effort of swimming upstream.
Daniel: The keyboard.
QWERTY oh, well, the keyboard doesn't
have to be that way.
Well, yeah, but we don't need keyboards
and we haven't always had them and we
won't always have them.
And left to right reading, it could be
right to left or up to down or it could
be any, but we haven't even had
inscription technology.
So maybe let me bring it back to your
experience with hip hop.
How has the generative process, the
extended cognitive niche of technology,
supported the remix culture?
And how does that manifest?
Baba: Well, I think I'll start with some
of the good ones.
I used to go to a studio and sit with
producers and hear their beats and like,
let's go with that one, and then like,
try lyrics.
I had prewritten or sometimes write the
track.
It was really expensive, fun,
interactively.
I do miss the in person studio
experience.
But all the previous rap records I've
made for the past ten years were all made
remotely with dropbox.
So the rappers, you know, send, or the
producers send me a folder full of
beats.
I choose the one that I like the best.
I write the rap, I record the raps at
home, I send them to the producer.
And I've got a track where the producer
is based in Seattle, the session musician
is playing, keys is in Vancouver.
The vocalist is doing the song from his
place in Toronto and I'm in Long Island.
Like taking all the different parts and
editing them and then sending them to the
mix engineer and the master.
It's like this great distributed
collaborative process.
And even by today's standard, that's
analog, right?
That's like sharing files in a dropbox
and throwing them into your local studio
and sort of measuring each input against
the expectation song to sound ultimately,
and giving people feedback and asking for
revisions.
But I think there are now AI sort of web
three platforms where you can all be in
the same virtual room and the latency is
worked out and you're collaborating
musically.
Haven't used those yet, but I've been
scoping them out.
So I think that's generally been
positive.
It's brought the cost down and it's
allowed for real time.
Well, not quite real time, but like,
ongoing collaboration with creatives
across different areas.
But then the kind of parallel revolution
that's happened is from selling CDs,
selling tape, selling CDs, and then
Spotify takes over and you're getting
like fractions of pennies on the stream.
And your music is going into this massive
archive of every kind of music.
And you're only getting paid based on how
much your music is listened to compared
to every other music that's on there.
They're partitioning their subscription
fees and it's become much harder, I
think, for a lot of musicians to make a.
Living from the sale of music.
And so over the past ten to 15 years,
that process really pushed a lot of
artists into really just basing all their
income on live performance, like set up
gigs and rock shows and sell merchant
shows.
If you want any expectation of income
from music sales, you better be there
meeting the fans, shaking their hands,
sending them a CD in person, then COVID
shut that down for a couple of years
anyway, it's coming back.
But my estimation during the pandemic was
even as it comes back, there's going to
be people that are more reluctant to
travel to shows and do that have the in
person experience, even when public
health notices say it's safe because
people have different degrees of paranoia
and anxiety and they won't feel as
comfortable even if it is objectively
safe.
So pivoting to this event wrap game was
partially based on an analysis of what's
happening with the industry and how hard
it is to make it as an artist.
And part of that has been a technology
driven process.
Daniel: Wow.
Also many ways to go, let's kind of
return to those expectations and I think
there'll be some ways that your
experience with expectations might map or
resonate to the Bayesian brain.
So say a little bit about what are your
expectations when you're coming out to a
performance, whatever setting that you
choose to think about, and then how does
that interface with or to what extent do
you even preempt or pregame the
audience's expectation?
Do you just call it like you see it or
are you looking to finesse your
performance based upon what you rightly
or wrongly believe their expectations to
be?
Baba: Well, there's an ambient
characteristic that I kind of just take
for granted, which is that I'm not very
famous, but I have a hardcore boutique
fan base of the science nerds and science
rap nerds.
So if I'm in front of a crowd most of the
time, more than half of them don't even
know who I am and I've got to introduce
myself to them for the first time.
And some portion of them have seen a
bunch of my shows and their fans and
they're like, oh, it's his next show.
But I don't really write to address an
audience that knows me generally.
My assumption is that they don't and I'm
constantly reintroducing myself and
finding new fans that way.
And let's be honest, you see me walking
down the street, you're not going to be
like, there goes a rapper.
The Bayesian priors of my ability to
perform as a rapper are low and they have
been since I started.
I was as bookish, suburban Canadian
woodsy teenager.
Like, I want to be a rapper, but no one's
going to believe I'm a rapper, so I
better get really good at rapping.
And also just it is a bit of a choice not
to like, dress overtly to hip hop or talk
overtly to hip hop.
It's like there is a hip hop persona that
a lot of artists adopt.
Maybe it becomes natural to them and they
could say, this is who I am.
There was either a conscious or
unconscious decision at some point in
their growth where they became more
seemingly hip hop.
Maybe to reduce the cognitive dissonance
of the lack of expectations of them being
able to wrap from their audience.
Maybe for other reasons, maybe peer
influence, maybe they just none of that
analysis really matters.
And they felt it.
They were passionate, so they started
adopting the lingo.
I kind of always partitioned rap a little
bit.
Like when I'm performing, I'm a rapper
and my profession is I'm a rapper, but
I'm not going to make myself a cup of tea
in a rap style.
Baba rapping: You know what I'm saying?
Baba: It's like I do distinguish a little
bit between the domains of my life and
partially what that means is people don't
mark me and expect me to be good at it or
to be able to deliver.
And then I get to there's a cost benefit
there, right?
For one thing, the skepticism might lose
me potential opportunities to perform or
potential members of the audience who see
me setting up the mic and they're like,
that guy?
I don't think so, and then leave.
But on the other hand, the transformation
I get to take an audience through as they
realize what they're experiencing and
feel their expectations being overturned
is actually, I think, really part of the
joy of the experience.
It's an expectation shattering experience
when someone that you don't expect to be
able to deliver in a certain art form
just really does.
And I kind of play with that in the
comedy and tease the audience for having
low expectations with me and stuff like
that.
But then part of this is contingent on me
just never getting that famous.
If there was a point at which I had
achieved as much as much of a fan base as
them, my, like, writing style about, you
don't think I'm going to be able to rap,
do you?
While watch this would of course, sounds
pointless.
Kind of like he stopped writing about
being poor after his first album and the
first line of his second album was, they
say I can't rap about Lee and broke no
more.
Just like naming the critical reception
of his transition from album one to
Millionaire album two.
So I think there is a kind of interplay
between artists and their audiences and I
stay niche and I write to the
expectations of that niche.
Daniel: We're all in our own niche, so I
hope that part doesn't change.
But very interesting, when we attend, we
don't even need to say pay attention and
use this economic modality.
But when we attend to our experience and
update our priors just statistically,
that's called learning.
And I think that speaks to this synthesis
with the language, the lexicon, the
slang, or as we might call it, the active
inference.
Ontology speaks across a continuum from
the experiential and the folk ecological,
the day to day, it's the same terms with
the same authentic relationships that are
increasingly becoming embodied in our
intelligence algorithms.
Again, not even calling it artificial
intelligence algorithms because they're
extensions into the niche from us.
So these cognitive models that are being
deployed, AI artificial intelligence or
large language models, they are cognitive
entities and they're participating in
these ecosystems of engagement with us.
Baba: I had a conversation with the new
Chat GPT driven Bing engine last night.
I just got added to Bing, the AI driven
version.
It's interesting.
The first thing I did when Chat GPT came
out was I said, write me a rap song in
the style of Snoop that explains how to
change the oil in a Honda CRV, because
that's exactly the kind of project that
we do with Event Wrap.
Event Wrap is like a team of skilled,
professional, ten year veteran artists
that'll make you a song on any topic and
either record it as a video that you can
share as a kind of public engagement, or
explainer or come in live to one of your
events, virtual or in person, and
perform.
But it's a topical rap agency.
It's like all the rappers have their own
catalogs, but they don't perform them at
the events we book.
They always create all new stuff.
And Chat GBT's Honda CRV oil change wrap
in the style of Snoop was like, uncannily
on point.
It had the Snoop doble g lingo.
It was like an accurate description of
the steps that you would have to take to
change the oil in your CRV.
It was like a cogently.
From the scripting perspective, I felt
like we had a threat on our hands.
Chat Gbt has definitely shook a lot of
people's professions, marketing copy,
professors, academics that's writing
papers.
The economics of this thing have not even
begun to dawn on people yet.
But the question in my mind was, how soon
is it coming for the rapper's job?
And there was a sophomoric cartoonish
kind of kindergarten flavor to the way
it's constructing bars.
So Chat Gbt and Bing by extension, I
think it's the same layer that's running
it is.
It writes wraps like someone who's never
wrapped before.
So if I told you, write me a wrap, you
could do it.
But there's like, layers of proficiency,
of master level stuff, of syncopation and
internal rhythm within the main stresses
of the bars.
And especially, and this is where I was
chatting about with Bing last night, is
polycellabic rhyme.
So polysyllabic rhyme seams are like the
construction of multisyllable rhymes out
of parts of other words.
And I was like, asking Bing, can you do
polysyllabic rhymes?
And Bing was like, yes, I can.
And I said, okay, give me some examples
from mainstream rap of polysyllabic
rhymes and it pulled an example from MF.
Doom, which was an excellent example.
It was like, the girl's a crazy skitzo,
but she's got amazing tits though, so you
can hear the pattern.
Crazy skitzo, amazing tits, though.
It's like multiple words constructing a
longer pattern of syllables.
I was like, Gravo, Bing, you found a
perfect polycellabic rhyme.
Now write me a wrap that explains your
internal data architecture or your
algorithmic architecture in the style of
MF.
Doom emphasizing polysyllabic rhymes.
Couldn't do it all monosyllabic.
Like, check me out.
I'm bing.
I do averse.
I am artificial intelligence.
I don't even need to rehearse.
And I was like, Bing, those are not
polysyllabic rhymes.
You started out quoting MF.
Doom complex five syllable rhyme pattern,
and now you're rhyming rehearse with
verse.
Like, don't insult my intelligence.
I was like, dissing the AI.
And I was like, I'm sorry, I'm a new
model and I will get better at
polysyllabic rhyme.
But basically, that is the thing that's
got our job safe for now.
Because if rap is an elite art form that
takes a decade or more to master, the
techniques of flowing, live freestyling
polysyllabic rhyme and rhythm patterns,
and also just the confidence to perform
are the things that we're still getting
paid for.
Even if ability to write a basic
competent rap is now easily achievable by
AI.
Daniel: I'm sure even outside of the rap
profession, these conversations are
happening.
They certainly are in research and
education.
Previously, the artifacts that we exuded
into our niche were mnemonic almost at
best.
It was probably transformative when some
of these oral traditions were able to be
written down.
And that may have also been seen as
threatening to the underlying basis of
the skill and the transmission.
And now we have just a brief window of
these inert externalized artifacts.
These mnemonic devices have only existed
aka writing for however long they've been
in the niche.
And now it's like they've come not quite
to life, but certainly to activity.
And now these off sourced and outsourced
cognitivist entities are not just
receiving and holding, but doing.
And that transforms who and what we are
in terms of our perception, cognition,
and action loops.
They're going to be different.
And that is what any given particular
thing is.
Baba: So you mean like any technological
innovation that changes how we interact
with each other and with our art forms?
Daniel: Yeah.
And from the technical side, we use the
word thing active inference lab to
describe the blanket and the internal
states.
So we take a particular partition, we
cleave off the thing we're talking about
from the environment.
The generative model of the thing is the
blanket and the internal states.
And so that thing is defined in terms of
its perception, cognition, internal
states, and action.
So when new sensory modalities or sense
data appear, when new action modalities
affordances appear, and when our thinking
is different, it's a different thing.
It isn't just like well, we mixed this
one thing with another thing, and they've
both retained their identity.
It's like there's been transformation and
a learning and we're in the middle of
some fractal dimension of it.
Baba: Yeah.
I think this is like a radical break from
previous technological changes.
One of the things I argued in my thesis
when I was a master's student was that
poets conceived of their audience and
their ability to connect with people
orally, primarily in CHAUCER's time,
right.
Reciting your poetry for a listening
crowd.
But then the invention of the printing
press with Gutenberg changed that ability
to imagine an audience because it was so
much easier to imagine a silent
readership of 10,000 people reading your
pamphlet.
But making 10,000 vellum manuscripts by
hand was always prohibitively expensive.
So no poet could even imagine ever having
a fan base through text.
Right.
Gutenberg allows for the possibility of a
fan base through text, which changes the
whole art form.
Suddenly rhyme is extraneous because
they're going to be reading quietly
anyway, so who cares what the poetry
sounds like?
The main thing should be carefully
constructed syntax and story and
semantics in a concentrated way.
But you see then this rise of free verse,
right?
Poetry is sort of like shorn of all of
its ornaments.
And my hypothesis was that they were just
basically irrelevant because people were
reading quietly and not reciting out
loud.
And then Edison invents recorded sound,
which creates the possibility of an
audience and fanbase that's just as vast
from the sound of your words as it would
be from the silent readership.
And that paves the way for the
possibility of hip hop, because this is
like people that are writing things
rhyming verse.
And of course, I call this the rhyme
renaissance, right?
Poetry was all rhymed then.
None of it was rhymed.
And then if you think of rap as poetry,
now it's all rhymed again, because who
cares about poetry?
Rap dominates, like, all of our verse
consumption compared to every other kind
of poetry out there.
Right.
And rap is rhymed.
And I think people instinctively resonate
with rhyme and just took a break from it
when they were reading silent pamphlets
published by poets who were imagining
their readership.
But each of these examples is like a
technological innovation that mediates
the creative process with its ability to
connect with an audience.
But this AI thing is something completely
different, isn't it?
It's like competing with us in our
production of the creative things.
And right now I'm taking some comfort in
the fact that it's competing ineptly it's
not as good at writing a rap as a good
rapper.
But I'm probably a subset of professions
that can still say that it's passing the
Lsat, it's passing all the masters entry
exams and which rarefied Anil Seth will
be left.
Maybe I could comfort to myself to say
the rapper will be the last to fall to AI
because of the combination of creativity
and semantic cogency and humor and all
the things that go into it that the AI is
going to have to work each of those out.
Like maybe stand up comics, too are safe
for a while because Jack Tvtpt can write
some jokes, but they're corny jokes
still, right?
The original jokes it writes aren't that
good compared to Dave Chappelle.
But what are we talking?
Like ten years of safe jobs as artists or
less?
The speed of this last six months has
been a little mind blowing.
Daniel: Who is the deep blue?
Who is the Gary Casperov of Performance.
What is the Turing test?
And for you to again calling back the
real recognized real I listen to that as
being like kind of a Turing Test is you
have cognitive entities in this moment of
reflection, which has been called Theory
of Mind and Active Inference Lab
sometimes is called thinking through
other minds.
Ttom because there's this cognitive
emulation of if I do this, then they'll
do that.
And so thinking through other minds used
to be a defined set of types of minds.
We had children.
We had adults like us.
We had adults in different cultures.
We had squirrels.
And then the workshop is open and the
composability is extreme, especially with
algorithms that can construct other
algorithms.
And all of a sudden that ecosystem of
shared intelligence thinking through
other minds.
We don't even know if it's a sports car
or a horse and buggy or a spaceship and
someone's like, do you want to get in?
And it's like, Where are we going?
What is it going to be like?
All those expectations that we might want
to have about a journey and an event and
who can say what with any precision?
Things will be like, So what do we do
then?
Baba: Yeah, except it's more like a
spaceship that the pilot is like, do you
want to get in?
If you don't, all these people are going
to die.
And so it's your choice whether you want
to get in but lives on the line.
Because obviously people that work in all
kinds of medical fields and scientific
fields will point directly to the amount
of human suffering that they're on the
verge of alleviating using these tools.
And the applications to rapper job
stealing are merely side effects
spandrels of the main focus of it, which
is, I think, mostly very laudable and
very necessary.
Right.
Let's not get on the spaceship means we
continue to put up with all kinds of
genetic diseases and levels of poverty
and public health crises and things like
that that the AI is being applied to and
is likely to do a great job in solving.
Daniel: Yeah, someone says, look, if your
four year old still wants to do art by
hand, we don't need to stop that, but we
just want to use it here.
That's going to be something that's very
challenging to take a long term
perspective on because it's going to seem
like a reasonable compromise in the
moment, just like everything always
does.
And what compromise was made when those
oral traditions were written down?
What compromise was made when that sheet
music became recorded and that became
canonical and distributed?
And so what is the nature of the
compromise and who's at the table in
2023?
Baba: Yeah, I think that's exactly the
right level of analysis.
And you can say on balance that each of
the compromises we made for some new
technology to give us some costs, but
also benefits.
It was a totally understandable and
reasonable one from the perspective of
like when I look at an individual poet
giving up on rhyme because they want to
do pamphlets and reach more people, I'm
like, well, they got a family to feed.
That's the way that they can achieve the
notoriety and a claim that is their path
to success as an individual.
And it has cultural ramifications
overall.
And I think you can put that people can
opt out of any technology and the people
that decide to opt in have totally
defensible personal choice reasons for
why they're doing so, usually to get a
competitive advantage.
That was the case with tools going back
to the Stone Age.
Right?
I only throw rocks, I don't use bow and
arrows and all right, you do you I'm
going to take down this antelope over
here.
We'll give you a piece if you're lucky.
That's the AI tool choice that everyone's
facing right now too.
Daniel: It also makes me think about art
always playing this role of like the tip
of the spear that kind of penetrates the
veil.
We had the discussion about Nfts as if
they were just a question about art.
But of course digital certificates are a
lot broader and more significant than
just visual images.
And there's a discussion about whether
certain kinds of art are being replaced
by generative algorithms.
Long ago, six months ago, twelve months
ago, when it was prechat GPT, but there
was a lot of the stable diffusion and
Midijourney type algorithms then the
conversation was more about graphical
design and professionals.
But of course that is a broader
discussion that isn't just about the
generation of images that you are paying
a creative professional to make.
And it's like art as this frontier and
mediator with the open ended.
Will people be looking for open endedness
and liminality in their events in 50
years?
I think they will be.
That niche, the marginal niche of art as
well as the central role of art, I think
it's fair to say we'll both exist now
whether that cultural attention on the
central artifacts will be about artifacts
made by a person, an algorithm or
something in between.
If somebody designs a 3D sculpture but
then it's printed, or if they think about
a drawing and then they use a pen that
was produced by a machine, who's to say
in these extended scenarios, whether one
or the other made it.
But in the margins, it's where we're
always going to be exploring in whatever
people call art.
And people who are in the middle of the
spotlight saying, that's not art, it's
not their art.
But every single genre has had to have
this mitosis or birthing process with
people who weren't part of that process
saying it wasn't art or that's not the
right way to do this kind of science.
Baba: Or rap is not music.
As a hip hop partisan, I'm very familiar
with defending against the rarefied taste
of people that want to gatekeep what
constitutes art and what doesn't.
But one thing I've always loved about
rap, like that aspect of it not being
gatekeep by Elitists.
If you want to be a professional ballet
dancer, like Billy Elliot's stories
notwithstanding, you got to try to get
into juilliard, and you have to go
through the process of rarefied judges
that are telling people who can and can't
get into the next one.
Lake there is no backdoor to success in
some art forms, right?
Classical music, opera.
But with hip hop, there's no front door
to success.
You got to get good at it.
On the street level, there's no degree
that will get you a job in it.
You just have to find crowds and
entertain them at the level of your
neighborhood and then your city and then
your state.
And if you survive the levels of
competition on the way up, then you get
to the world stage or whatever.
But it's very like, pick up a mic and
show what you got kind of thing.
And it's mediated by the audience and the
fans.
If they like it, it's right, and if they
don't like it, it's wrong.
And MC has moved the crowd, and there's a
fairly definitive objective measurement
about whether someone's doing rap well or
not, and it's how the crowd is
responding.
There's no valid argument that
everybody's booing you, but you're
actually awesome because they just don't
understand your art.
No, you failed to understand the context
in which your art was meant to be
consumed.
Right.
So whenever we're looking at these trade
offs, often it comes down to producers
and consumers, right?
Each new tool is good for consumers but
bad for producers.
And this is like the Taxi Guilds trying
to fight off Uber.
Uber is great for people that want to
ride, but it's bad for people that are
going to try to control the means of
production.
And you're seeing this exact process play
out with Chat GPT now, which is like and
also with stable diffusion and the other
examples you gave.
Like, people want to consume art and they
don't necessarily care who made it, as
long as their reception of it gives them
the feelings that they want from the
consumption.
Right.
And I think that's the case with music
and with poetry as well.
Although we're not yet consuming a ton of
AI generated music and poetry and comedy
because it's not sophisticated enough to
produce the highest level stuff.
Although I think with classical music it
is, and with graphic design andy Clark it
is.
Right.
The best AI art is actually competitive
commercially or from a consumer
perspective, like taste test wise with
the best rarefied professionals, which is
devastating for them, but it's not
unique.
That's what the guilds have wanted to do
for centuries is protect their status as
the elite producers of a thing from the
ability of just about anybody to consume
it for as cheaply as they want.
And that's what technology keeps
delivering.
And in general, I'm actually a fan of
that process.
I think it's democratizing.
It's good for everybody on average, even
though it perpetually upends the guilds.
But we shouldn't give guilds control over
our ability to consume excellence.
And if excellence is delivered better by
AI, then let's not be curmudgeons about
that.
But there is still an individual
challenge like, okay, what am I going to
do to make a living now?
It does really create a lot of potential
unemployment and economic devastation,
which is why a lot of people have thought
that there's just no escape from
universal basic income because the jobs
are going to fall and society will
descend into chaos with that much
unemployment and frustration and
resentment and anger.
But even if rappers are the last job to
fall, the analysis has to apply to all
kinds of other jobs first.
And active inference comes into this
because how does a rapper entertain the
crowd?
By having a mental model of what the
crowd's going to do if they perform
Action X, right.
What it will be the effect of X on Y.
Y is the crowd, x is the intervention and
the intervention is a choice of a bar.
I'm going to rhyme this with this.
I'm going to make a song about this
topic.
I'm going to try this joke out in my flow
as a punchline.
And you have a mental model.
Oh yeah, people are going to think that's
really funny.
And then you deploy it and you see the
degree to which your expectation has been
fulfilled.
And I don't think AI is that good at that
yet because it doesn't model expectations
of audiences very well yet, does it?
It doesn't have deep theories of mind, of
perceptions of perceptions of
perceptions.
It just has averaging abilities to
recreate patterns that it finds in vast
troves of human created art, which
includes pixel patterns and graphics and
patterns and text, semantic and syntactic
patterns.
But like performance art with an audience
requires a mental prior of the audience's
disposition and attitude.
And that's why I say rap is going to be
the last to fall.
And that's also why it's really hard to
get good at.
It takes years of performing, dying on
stage and sucking and being booed before
you really build up this mental model of
like, I know what people like and I know
if I do this, they'll do that.
And even I've been doing this for 25
years.
I'm wrong all the time.
Oh yeah, that line fell flat.
All good, all good.
Either you like carry on or you go fix
it.
That's where the AIS have to get to,
right?
Daniel: Wow, so much.
One thought was, rap will be the last to
fall and the first arise around that
campfire again.
It'll arise situationally.
Baba: You mean after society descends
into chaos and all the AIS are resting
and we're back to Spears, rap will be the
first to arise again.
Daniel: First in, last out.
Baba: What was the next thing?
Daniel: Another thought?
You mentioned tastemakers.
And I thought, what is the ultimate or
even the proximate taste maker?
It's our generative model of taste.
It's every person eating that dish.
The tastemaker isn't who told them to go
to the restaurant.
That's basically believing the hype and
using the paradigm of the advertising
industry.
The tastemaker is the taster.
That's who is generating the experience
of taste.
Taste isn't just in the dish before it is
actually eaten by that person, it's
experienced.
And they're going to have some previous
taste in their mouth or they're going to
have a context or a cultural
understanding or a memory, a trigger.
So the taste is generated authentically
and situationally.
And yeah, there's going to be a lot of
volatility as tastemaking becomes
actually understood to be personalized.
And that may look like the personal
generation of media, which has not even
been plausible.
When you had only 33 Rpm records, then
you have somebody selecting which ones to
distribute.
But when you have algorithms, it takes it
one level further which ones you like to
listen to.
People who like this also listen to
that.
And this is like, as far as we can see,
another level of like, you liked this.
We're going to regenerate that story so
that the person's voice is like that.
That takes it to the next level.
But also with enormous trade offs, it
brings it closer to how things really
are.
Baba: Well, that makes me think of
something we spoke on earlier, which is
the degree to which cultural norms are
able to reorganize or swim upstream
against instincts.
Right.
So when you say the taste maker is the
taster, the counter examples that jump to
mind are rappers who are like Jayz, where
he's like and before this song ends, I'm
going to start another trend.
If you want to say the tasters of the
taste makers, I'm looking at people who
merely suggest something is cool and it
instantly becomes cool.
And everybody is able to post hoc
rationalize reasons why it has intrinsic
qualities that they now recognize as
amazing over and above what the
tastemaker told them to do.
But we are highly susceptible primates to
cool factors.
And so I would suggest the taste maker.
Is not the taster.
The taste maker is the best predictor of
the average resonate of the tasters.
And when you get very, very good at
understanding instinctively how people
will react to the taste, using taste as a
metaphor for all kinds of art, then
you're able to be treated as
authoritative on taste because you're
right so often about what people will
like.
And that power of vested expertise from
your fan base then allows you to start
trends that are not just predictive.
You say something's great, and everybody
instantly believes it's great and
experiences it as great, as authentically
as if they had discovered it for
themselves and decided it was great
because they've recognized your actual,
real, vertical, average ability to
predict taste across groups.
Daniel: Awesome.
I thought, okay, again, who's the taste
maker?
It's the chef.
And not everyone's in the kitchen,
because a chef is in their position,
because they've been recognized to
repeatedly be able to construct dishes
that in the local taste making diners
like, or maybe just a few diners like.
And it's like, what?
You can't do that with molecular
gastronomy, but some so it's the chef and
it's the social influence network, and
it's local.
What framework can we use to think about
all of these interactions within and
among cognitive entities, within and
among their niche?
We use Active Inference as just a way of
thinking about it.
Well, what?
Active inference lab?
It's there in the title Action and
Inference.
It's involving action and doing cognitive
modeling.
And that gives us the composability and
the ability to reconfigure and remix, to
capture all of these diverse scenarios,
not to close the book on them, but to be
like, oh, wow, what an amazing question.
There's 50 PhDs of research that you
could go into.
So it's a question generator, and it's a
lens by people who are even just
beginning to learn it, who review
phenomena that they've already been told
or experienced in one light.
All of a sudden, they're seeing how it
can be reconfigured, for example, seeing
what we prefer in terms of what we expect
rather than what we prefer in terms of
what's rewarding, which is the reward
learning reinforcement paradigm which
proposes, well, maybe, you know, the
value of different states and you're
maximizing value.
It resonate with some contrast that with
you have this complex generative model,
and you're always referencing to it, and
you're taking actions and learning to
reduce your surprise bound, your surprise
of certain kinds, which could include
increasing your narrative surprise, and
you want that page turner or the horror
film.
So it just kind of reflects back.
And then one last point on Active
Inference as a research direction that
the nursery to hear your thoughts on is
it is happening in a time that has never
been seen before in research and
academia.
So you said there are certain careers or
genres where there's no back door to
success, and then you said in Rap,
there's no front door.
So traditionally, even if we could say
there was no back door to success in
research, the reality is there was a side
door, and people were getting kicked out
and being brought into the party through
the side door, and a bunch of people were
waiting at the front door.
They didn't even know that the show was
not happening that way.
We're developing a framework in community
at the speed of preprints ActInf
Livestream.
And so there's transdisciplinary
collaborations with philosophy,
historians of science, cognitivist,
researchers, mathematicians, physicists.
So there's a transdisciplinary
conversation and one with practitioners
and one that's happening with everybody
with view access to some large parts of
it, which wasn't even the case
previously.
Open science and research was like, break
down the paywalls.
Everybody should have access to the PDFs,
which is great, but it turns out that
having access to 200,000 PDFs, having
access to every single PDF that Karl
Friston has ever been an author on, it's
not even going to take you 10% of the way
unless you're going to engage in this
total monastic life to unpack them.
And the details aren't even in what's
necessarily those papers.
It's beyond that.
It's in the community, it's in the
software, in the inaction.
So, of course, wait and see.
But there's so much with the way that
active inference is developing on the
influence of previous frameworks Bayesian
brain and Bayesian statistics, causal
inference, statistical physics happening
in this sort of wrapping in front of the
crowd way asynchronously with the
preprints synchronously with remote
presentations and recordings, that it's
hard to think of another area that has
had that kind of a developmental niche.
Baba: You're saying active inference is
the hip hop of the scientific community?
Daniel: Basically, you said it, not me.
Baba: Live on the mic.
I love it.
Yeah.
And I think it's super exciting.
Research and collaboration happening, and
it's very unknown to the public.
If you try to explain what this
conversation is about, people understand
the idea of expectation and priors and
belief upgrading, the very sort of basic
version of the Bayesian algorithm, but
all the applications of it and the cross
disciplinary side and everything, it
needs more science communication.
I've made two Bayesian songs.
I think I need to make 20 more.
Because the applications of the research
are vast, and especially in the AI era,
people really need to know what these
algorithms are achieving and the ways in
which they are similar or different to
our own cognitive processes and what we
can expect them to achieve and how we can
expect them to help and what they're
threatening.
All that stuff goes through active
inference, doesn't it?
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, in our kind of closing segments,
would you like to do something musical or
how do you want to proceed?
Baba: Yes, indeed, I'd love to.
I'm very happy to do a demonstration of
one of the last art forms that AI is not
yet able to model and that is a freestyle
wrap.
So if we have anybody watching on the
stream or Daniel, you're welcome to do it
as well.
If you want to pop some phrases into the
text, I will look at the text that you're
displaying and also look at the comments
and the chats on YouTube.
And anything that I see pop up, I will
visually process and convert into rhymes
in a freestyle rap track just to give a
little insight into this process.
It is a violation and.
Baba rapping: Expectation setting.
Baba: And expectation violating process.
Right.
Like the active listener to a freestyle
rap is trying to figure out the semantics
and figure out where the rap is going to
go.
And the rapper is also in real time
figuring out the semantics because it's
completely unscripted, but it's at the
same time trying to set up expectations
of the audience and violate them.
I think a lot of the fun is the surprise
factor of like, oh, I didn't expect him
to go there.
I thought he was going to go there, but
oh, now I see it's kind of like a game of
chase, like the rabbit and the fox.
So I see Sean Kelly's, drop Topology in
the chat of YouTube.
I'm going to start there and I'm going to
kick a little rap for you guys.
Baba rapping: This is hip hop, tell me
what you think this is.
It's Barbara Brinkman rock.
And now an active infrared.
That's the infrared looking for.
Where info is, I don't know, but I feel
it's kind of intimate.
Yes, indeed, hip hop.
What you think this is, is Bubba Brinklin
here on the active infraring podcast.
I'm looking for where the info is so I
could update my priors and get into it
and maybe drop a beat.
Sean Kelly said topology.
Yes, right now I'm rocking hip hopology.
Can't you even see that's?
How I just abuse in trouble topology.
That means checking all the levels and
looking for the map and the different
levels of impact.
I'm spitting rap.
Yes, I'm looking at the chat.
That's how I kick it, yes, how I go with
rap and flows.
It is me kicking it with Mr.
Danielle Freedman.
How I'm speaking.
Yes, I'm always just deleting variants
every time.
I'm sometimes just weekend through the
speakers.
I just do this on a Tuesday or a week.
And indeed, active inference is how I'm
speaking.
I'm sneaking past all your expectations
like a Rhett and amaze because my raps
will amaze.
And yes, I'm doing polysyllabic to
amaze.
I'm just having to blaze.
Yes, I'm actively playing all the
different rhymes on my brain like a
piano, changing the channels like I'm
rocking ganks at Tony Soprano.
Yeah, that's okay.
This is how I just anger the listeners
sometimes because raps are danger.
Got to give a shout out to Tucker Cat
Hill Chambers who rocked this with us.
Yes, working the angles like Base theorem
can you even hear them when I'm near
them.
I start to see it as this math scientific
theorem that I could apply to every
single thing.
As Barbara Brinkman gets all your neurons
jingling.
It's how I attacked it.
I attracted.
I'm massive.
I'm active when I'm doing.
Inference in my rap and indeed this is
how I kick it when I enter my rap is
directed it's never non censored as I
just try to construct it mistakes I
make?
Sometimes I'm run DMC and sometimes I'm
drake except I'm not quite as good of a
singer with the melodies.
But then again, I've got the free steve's
that kick a lot active inference lab,
Bayesian styles, freestyles that's trying
to make the people smile as they listen
in yes, that's how I'm straight rock and
even Ahmad Mostafi says yo wow.
Awesome with explosion emojis baba
Brinkman coming with the dope beats
people are like, hopefully he's one of
those MCs becca rock straight up as
ancient hip hop like rock him and Eric
B.
I never do it terribly.
I just freestyle.
That is improv, which means it's
spontaneous.
My style is the Zania some repping for
the Long Islanders plus the Canadians
people listen and blow their brains when
I'm blazing it yeah, that's how it goes
when I'm speaking on the basics I'm in
Long Island, but Daniel he's up in Davis,
California I put it on you.
It's act of inference boba Brickman.
When I'm speaking it, I'm getting into it
looking for where the info is.
That's how I'm rocking.
This was like a four minute continuous
talk and demonstration.
Yes, indeed.
I'll make it easy.
Let's say you do this shit chat Gpt-3.
You can't do it.
You can't freestyle over this music and
use a brain to actively infer that's so
fluid.
Yes, that's a rap that I make up and
invent the last four minutes has been an
event prescribed in the time.
That's the freestyle wrap that I did on
this concept.
That's how I can adapt.
Yes, indeed, that's a rhyme that I had to
make.
I can do this.
My brain makes me a primate.
But I don't make mistakes.
Okay, sometimes I do, but that's just
mutation.
Yes, that's how I move all the mistakes
get integrated.
Baba: My work is huge.
Baba rapping: Thank you, Ahmad.
Mustafi.
I appreciate you.
Okay, now I'm starting to wind down.
Baba: And trying to just find a new.
Baba rapping: Direction for the rhyme
sound.
This is how I just get into it.
It's Baba Brickman rockin with active
infrareds, active infraring.
This is how I'm never pretending I'm.
Baba: Trying to infer some way for the.
Baba rapping: Rap ending, but wait a
second.
This is how I do it.
Hip hop.
Baba: The easiest solution is just turn
the music off, bra.
All right, that's freestyle rap.
And I really appreciated this chat.
It was a ton of fun and super
interesting.
Daniel: I'll give a closing remark and
then any last words from you?
It brought a smile and a laugh to my face
and body because another individual was
engaging in the shared moment.
I've seen language models output
incredible X in the style of Y, and every
single time it brings a chuckle or less
and it's like, okay, I kind of expected
it to do that.
I'm disappointed if it can't fulfill my
request because it's like, Well, I asked
you this because I expected you to do
that.
When there's joyful, spontaneous
engagement that is reflective of a shared
experience, it's the real thing.
And when that lens is applied, it's going
to be real recognizing real.
And I don't think humans will be out of a
relationship role for each other for a
long, long time.
Baba: Amen to that.
And I just want to say that the phrase
that you just coined joyful, spontaneous
experience, that's joyful, spontaneous
engagement that's reflective of a shared
experience that is basically the entire
value proposition of my event rap company
is Find.
A topic or an event or something that
creates collective attention of a group
and have that be the locust and the
catalyst of a rap.
Because the rap game is entirely
predicated on make a thing that is very
widely appreciated and goes viral and is
hugely massive and making general purpose
art is what most rappers are focusing
on.
And I really thought it would be
interesting to apply a rapper skill to
this joyful, shared experience and
spontaneity challenge, and thank you for
giving me a platform for it.
And I hope your audience will now imagine
every other possible application of a
shared experience that a rapper could add
value to, because if such things occur,
then my business will succeed and lots of
rappers will get lots of gigs wrapping in
weird places like this.
And I think that would add to the joyful
variety of the world and the genre.
Daniel: Amazing.
So thank you so much, Baba.
Always welcome to come back.
Give us updates when that wrap guide to
active inference drops.
Baba: All right, I'm on it.
I'm on it.
Daniel: Thank you.
Baba: Thanks, Daniel.
Daniel: Peace.